Is there any reason a person should not take Ivermectin?
Yeah, there's a lot of reasons why a person should not take Ivermectin.
So, understand, there's a few years ago, we didn't hear about Ivermectin.
I've been doing this for what? What are you six, seven years taking care of people that have a
cancer diagnosis? Oh, we never heard of Ivermectin. We never heard of that.
Years ago, and there was all sorts of, you know, talk about other things that, you know,
where everybody had to do this or everybody had to do that. Back in the early 2000s,
everybody had to juice and go on a vegan raw food diet. Well, that's just absolutely nonsense
that that anybody should say everybody should blah, blah, blah for the most part. Yeah,
everybody should eat better and stay away from toxins and everybody should stay away from sugar
and, you know, and get back to, you know, living the way God created us to live.
But as far as like taking a medication that every cancer patient should take Ivermectin,
I just totally disagree with that. I don't think that unless your cancer is like growing like crazy,
I don't think that you should just be throwing the kitchen sinket that I hear that phrase a lot.
Like I just want to throw the kitchen sinket this and do everything. Well, there could be danger
of that. Number one, you could overload your liver, you could damage your liver, you could damage
your kidneys, you could damage your cells because Ivermectin and Mendezol are drugs. They're toxins,
they're medications that if they don't detoxify, they could damage your liver and could be stored
in your cells and could be a source of other problems. Even herbal supplements taking too much of a
good thing and be a bad thing. So I don't think you should take too much stuff but I don't think you
should do too many things all at the same time. You know, if your cancer is stable and not growing,
then I don't think you should add Ivermectin or Mendezol. I think you should add things or change
your protocol if your cancer is going the wrong way. So I'm a big fan of Ivermectin. Don't get me wrong
and I'm a huge fan of Mendezol. Don't get me wrong. But certainly we do not have all of our
patients slash members on either one of those things. And if you're stable and doing well, I don't think
you should add it just because you saw a clip on Instagram or Facebook or something like that
and then you feel guilty that you're not taking it. You should do that. Don't don't make decisions
that way. So you know, that's what we're here for to test you. That's what we're here for to answer
these kind of questions. I don't think everybody should be on these things. These things can be toxic
and though they're considered quote-unquote safe medications, it doesn't mean they don't
they're without side effects. And it doesn't mean that they're without dangers either. So you have to
be careful in doing any of those things.